we've certainly wanted to be with each
other and as we're all talking about
taking industrial action again and being
together to talk about how we coordinate
that and make that action as powerful as
it can possibly be so I'm not going to
say much more but I'm going to hand over
to colleagues to talk about the position
of their unions and then we'll open it
up to questions once we've once you've
finished I haven't sorted an order out
but as you finish it first Kevin perhaps
I'll go to you first Kevin and then
Patrick and Jeff
okay come on thanks Paul and thanks very
much to the nht for the invitation to be
at this joint uh press conference and
welcome to press colleagues I think the
government should pay close attention to
this joint press conference they should
be concerned about it none of the unions
on this table want to take strike action
none of us want to disrupt education or
parents working lives but all of us
believe that we are engaged in something
with a high moral purpose and we are
prepared and that's what the
significance of this is there is a
preparation to take industrial action if
necessary
the government should pay attention I
think all of us are saying that we want
we use different words to describe this
there needs to be a correction to the
pay of teachers so that we can start to
address the crisis in teacher
Recruitment and the crisis in teacher
retention our schools need to be
properly funded to award that any such
correction and we're calling for the
government to invest in this generation
of children
I I want
um the Neu has has another strike on
Tuesday we will start a rebalot the
government requires rebalance every six
months
but we're in anticipation that we can
coordinate action in the Autumn term
with other unions
and I think it's important to say to
Jillian Keegan I'll stop with this she
can't Outsource this problem to the
Estee Hobby
the stlb is not an untrammeled
independent process the government
appoints the members it sets the remit
it sets the affordability limit
the sdrb is not binding arbitration it
makes a recommendation but the Secretary
of State can still vary it and so the
stlb is unlikely to be the settlement of
this dispute only Jillian Keegan can
settle it she should be working with us
now to find a solution to end the
dispute
yeah well thanks very much uh Paul and
uh good afternoon uh colleagues really
grateful to Paul and the naht for
um allowing us to uh Gate Crash your uh
your your conference in this way but
this these are important times uh and
the significance of
um for Union general secretaries being
aligned in this way I don't think could
be should be understated it's a real
demonstration of of Unity on our part
and determination on the part of us and
our members after weeks if not months of
stonewalling from the Secretary of State
I mean as a reminder colleagues not that
you need reminding Julian Keegan was
after asked us to consult our members
over her pay offer and we did that
colleagues we did that in good faith and
our members told her what they thought
of her pay offer that it's neither Fair
nor reasonable two words that the
Secretary of State keeps on using fair
and reasonable neither of those neither
does it provide for pay restoration and
since the time of our consultation with
our members and since our members
emphatically rejected uh that payoffer
the secretary of state has gone to
ground
she's not talking to us
now her haste to strike a weak and
underfunded deal in just six days how
seriously backfired hence we're here
today it's galvanized not just us
but actually our members Rank and file
classroom teachers and school leaders
who are now going to be balloted for
industrial action throughout four unions
now I hear the prime minister is saying
that unions need to negotiate well our
four unions want nothing more than to be
able to sit down and negotiate we've
repeatedly asked the Secretary of State
to return to the negotiating table she
started negotiations and now she should
see them through it's the Secretary of
State just to be clear the Secretary of
State not the strb that will make the
decisions in respect of teachers pay now
I understand that secretary of state
says that she's a good negotiator but I
have to tell you this I I'm not so sure
we're not so sure that the secretary of
state is a good negotiator all that
she's up to the job and if Jillian
Keegan isn't k capable of finding a
resolution to our disputes then the
government needs to find someone who is
up to the job someone up to the job of
fixing that crisis in Recruitment and
Retention of dealing with the real
funding pressures that Kevin referred to
in our schools of ending the toxic
culture of excessive workload and high
working hours and giving teachers and
head teachers to pay and rewards that
they deserve so our members are saying
today that they've been left with no
other option if the government walks
away from the table after the crisis
that they've created over 13 years then
we have been forced to balance our
members and we are doing so this term so
that we together with our sister trade
unions Asel naht and the Neu our members
will be standing together to demonstrate
that the power of the teaching
profession and the opposition of
teachers to pay restrained and thoughts
to real terms pay so once again today I
have to say this to Jillian Keegan
return to the negotiating table
work with us to agree a deal on Pi that
will command the support of the teaching
profession or deal with the consequences